oh no big deal
so ancestry brought me here today to
learn the job of one of my ancestors and
I have no idea what that is for work I'm
a producer TV screens and laptops and
cameras I don't think they had a lot of
that stuff back then so I don't know how
but I do with this to be honest
can I bring in my buddy Adam he's kind
of like my moral support for the day
amen you think they could and I'm so
curious this is my grandmother so then
Johnson and Dorothy Williams okay so
that's my great grandmother Dorothy Wow
makes in here I know Aaron was my
three-times-great-grandfather so my
great-great great-grandfather man
thinking of that 1865 so five years
after slavery ended in Alabama and read
can write oh man that's like yeah that's
huge
our family has come so far and had so
much success and and they set the tone
fonts on patterning great-grandfather so
this is the 1930s United States federal
census his name is Franz and the reason
I didn't recognize frogs is because I
knew his Frank they were trying to like
assimilate to being American he speaks
two languages which is already better
than your great grandson sorry I totally
okay says uh he's a machinist huh oh
wait oh here we go
at the lumberyard so a machinist at the
lumberyard
bring it on you got this you got this
[Music]
welcome to the sauna thank you what
you're gonna do today is you're gonna
take this rough cut piece of lump and
we're gonna mill it in two dimensional
lumber press that but when I heard
lumber machine is my head started
spinning a little bit I was kind of
think of that make sense yeah my
family's kind of good at this stuff now
I get to see the source of it my
great-grandfather did exactly these
things this is actually the traditional
jointer and this would have been
definitely his era so this machine would
have existed yes I really yeah he might
actually even work on this I love that
I'm just gonna put that in my mind this
is it it's a weird thing to get to put
yourself in the shoes of your ancestor
because it creates this connection you
can't put your finger on but it's a
really special feeling though now you're
gonna take that to the bandsaw this one
I feel like looks a little bit more
modern but was this something that I
know this would have definitely been his
definitely
that sound when it starts loving I think
everybody should try something like this
don't learn about your grandparents
it'll make you feel more connected to
just being on this earth I want to keep
going I want to study can I do certain
8:00 in the morning
my great-grandfather created a legacy
and it kind of puts things in
perspective from my own life to think
about what might I do that is going to
lay that groundwork for my family so the
generations from now I won't be here but
my family will know look what let me
grandpa Joshua did it helps me connect
more to the past and gets me more
excited about the future
[Music]